- This footage shows El Salvador's
answer to gang violence.
Thousands of alleged gang members
stripped down to expose their tattoos
in a brand new mega prison
set to house 40,000 inmates.
(speaking in foreign language)
Gangs turned El Salvador's murder rate
into one of the highest in the world.
And to end this cycle of violence,
the country's President, Nayib Bukele,
ordered a crackdown in March last year
arresting more than
66,000 people since then.
Communities say the streets are safer
but rights groups and some residents
argue that this change
has come at a high price.
That innocent men and women
and even minors have been rounded up
and held indefinitely
without access to lawyers.
(speaking in foreign language)
I'm here in El Salvador to
gauge the impact of this effort,
and what it means for
families and communities,
and for our Central American country
that has been gripped by
gang violence for decades,
stoking both poverty and
migration towards the US.
(dramatic music)
In El Salvador, a country
the size of Massachusetts
and with a population of 6.3 million,
the violence has been blamed on the MS 13
and the 18th Street gangs,
groups that originated
among Salvadorians in the US in the 1980s.
They terrorized communities
for decades in El Salvador,
demanding weekly extortion payments
from business owners and imposing curfews.
In 2015, El Salvador's murder rate
was over 100 per 100,000 people.
But by 2022, officials said
the number went down to 7.8.
(speaking in foreign language)
President Nayib bukele
imposed a state of emergency
where lawmakers suspended
constitutional guarantees,
allowing soldiers to raid communities
in search of anyone with
suspected gang ties.
(soldiers speaking in foreign language)
The mass arrests gave
El Salvador the world's
highest incarceration rate as
1% of the national population
has been put behind
bars over the past year.
As a result of the crackdown,
gang members are no longer
prevalent in communities.
Small businesses can
now operate without fear
and at any time of the day
without having to pay high extortion fees.
But the offensive fractured
many of the poorest households.
Tens of thousands of young children
have had at least one parent or caregiver
detained under the declared
state of emergency.
Anna Mancia says her four adult children
were working as street vendors
when they were detained last year.
(speaking in foreign language)
She was left to take care
of six grandchildren.
None of them go to school and
Anna struggles to feed them.
Families like Anna's can't
afford legal representation.
Alejandro Diaz Gomez is
a nonprofit attorney.
He advises 250 families of detainees
who he says are wrongfully held.
(speaking in foreign language)
Rights groups say people are locked up
in crowded cells with little food
while they wait indefinitely for trial.
This man told us his
two sons were arrested
during the crackdown last year.
(civilian speaking in foreign language)
El Salvador's Security
Minister Gustavo Villatoro
denied allegations of human rights abuses
and arbitrary detentions,
adding that all gang members will spend
the rest of their lives behind bars
More than a year into the crackdown.,
President Bukele's approval
rating is at a record high.
(crowd cheering)
(announcer speaking in foreign language)
Polls at the start of the year
showed more than 90% of Salvadorians
are happy with the
President's security effort.
And El Salvador's model
has drawn the attention
of other Latin American countries gripped
by violent crime such
as Ecuador and Honduras.
Political analysts say,
the crackdown's popularity
could pave the way for bukele
to seek reelection next year.
While the country's constitution
does not allow a president
to have consecutive terms in office,
he has said he plans to run again.
(crowd cheering)
(gentle music)